[Music]
so yeah this is what I do I'm a TV host
but you know what I did before this I
waited tables at Bennigan's know what I
did before this not immediately before
this was like hey guys I'm sorry to
interrupt
Southwest sampler right real good real
good feel good this is Kerry she's
taking over I got to run to TBS doesn't
like that I used to wait tables at
Bennigan's in Chicago and I loved it I
loved being a waiter everybody called me
moose big guy called moose nametag said
moose when I clocked out I'd get on the
restaurant PA and go the Moose is loose
moose is true good times and you know
what else I loved about being a waiter
maybe the most was the tips not just the
money but like working for tips I love
working for it because being a waiter is
kind of like the American dream
the harder you work the more you can
make it's kind of like Scarface only
waiters do slightly more cocaine I'm
just kidding moose was drug free yeah
was but here's what I want to say
publicly about tips some people don't
know this but waiters don't make an
hourly wage you do but you get like a
check for 12 cents like do I work at a
lemonade stand so I just want to get
this out there the tips aren't extra the
tips are all of it that's how they get
paid so tip your waiters well give them
an extra dollar who cares
[Applause]
you'll make somebody's day and their
rent think of the service industry like
the original Kickstarter but you're
helping to fund a person's groceries and
their self-worth instead of an indie
movie your friends are trying to make
about wind farms grow it's called
blowing in the wind we only need 80
grains that's a good idea wind isn't the
only thing that blows Kevin forget
Kickstarter give it to a waiter they're
giving you a lot in exchange you get hot
food endless refills and sometimes some
very convincing flirting from a girl in
a bowtie so can I have some extra cheese
honey you can have whatever you want
[Applause]
extra cheese that's code for sex I'm
gonna give her more than just the tip
okay but here's the rule for good
service tip 20% and I know that freaks
some people out you're not good at math
neither am i I'll make it easy move the
decimal point over one double that
number it's simple if the bill is $30
move it over three times two is six
tip six bucks if it's 40 slight why am I
doing this I think you got it there's
one guy at home like wait wait what a
good charity
why am I even explaining this on
late-night anyway well when did this
become Schoolhouse Rock just like but
here's where it gets more complicated
because sometimes 20% isn't enough I'll
tell you when I call that time breakfast
breakfast is cheap as and that
waitress busts her ass for you so
sometimes it doesn't end up fair like
bringing someone three types of juice
everybody left every juice all the
juices you have just for me that's one
tray of goddamn juice just for one guy
eggs they bring you eggs that are
impossibly still hot that's not easy and
bacon cooked to your exact
specifications just like listen I want a
crispy old crispy all right but I want
to have a little bit gift
Bluebird yeah you know what I mean like
cook it but they like taken out right
when it's like like you know like ideas
kind of like somewhere in between like a
poker chip and a fruit roll-up
she's sweating running out of the
kitchen like Vishnu forearms each one
lined with five plates they got a
short-order cook screaming
constantly slamming that Bell with a
spatula robo-moe
now after all of that trauma your
breakfast bill comes out to like 475
this is where 20% doesn't work
20% of 475 is like 90 cents if you leave
that hardworking breakfast waitress a 90
cent tip you deserve to be banned from
breakfast five extra bucks she's been up
since 5:00 I am setting up the patio
while it was still dark you haven't seen
the bottom of the coffee cup since you
walked in and if you had the audacity to
tip her barely enough to snap into a
slim jim yourself
[Applause]
[Music]